[Musik]
jetzt die Prognose für die
Bundestagswahl
es ist nur die erste Prognose nicht 100%
richtig aber die Tendenz stimmt die drei
ampelparteien siegesgewiss
das Wetter in langer Wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele Bürger und Bürger ihr Kreuz
bei der SPD gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es ein Wechsel in der Region
gibt und auch weil sie wollen dass der
nächste Kanzler dieses Landes Olaf
Scholz hat die FDP hat eines der besten
Wahlergebnisse in ihrer Geschichte
erzählt
diesmal hat es noch nicht gereicht aber
wir haben einen Auftrag für die Zukunft
es ist ein knappes Ergebnis Ende
September es gibt noch viele
Möglichkeiten wer mit wem die Politik
der nächsten Jahre bestimmen wird
[Musik]
deutschland hat gewählt und es gibt auf
jeden Fall einen neuen Kanzler nach 16
Jahren Angela Merkel wer regiert mit wem
und wer sitzt künftig auf den
Oppositionsbank die Machtverhältnisse
haben sich verschoben der Wahlabend ist
noch in vollem Gange da gibt es bereits
den ersten überraschenden Vorschlag nun
ja das Wahlergebnis ist nicht ganz
einfach zu lesen etwa 75% der Deutschen
haben die Partei eines nächsten Kanzlers
nicht gewählt und deshalb Herr Bäcker
könnte es ratsam sein das Grüne und FDP
zuerst miteinander sprechen um dann all
das was danach kommt zu strukturieren
kurze Nachfrage Frau willburg werden sie
dazu bereit sozusagen zuerst mit Herrn
Lindner zu sprechen bevor die großen die
Wahlsieger 1 und 2 dran sind
den letzten Tagen
dass diese Logik da ist einer der alle
anderen anruft dass diese Logik dem
Aufbruch den wir in unserem Land
nicht gut tut ob also rot oder schwarz
ins Kanzleramt kommt darüber verhandeln
zunächst grün und gelb die
Strippenzieher bringen sich in Stellung
FDP und Grüne wollen vorsundieren guten
morgen allerseits in die Runde am Tag
danach
es ist eine gute Idee dass diejenigen
die erstmal am weitesten weg sind auf
der politischen Skala mal gucken ob sie
miteinander was hinkriegen und eine
Brücke bauen können zwischen Grüne und
FDP gibt es die größten inhaltlichen
Unterschiede in der Vergangenheit waren
sich FDP und Grüne vor allem darüber
einig dass sie sich über kaum etwas
einig sind verbunden in herzliche
Abneigung
die angebliche neue Volkspartei sie
Renten die Welt liebe Freunde was für
eine Überheblichkeit mir ist nicht klar
mit welchen Inhalten die FDP antritt
aber gut unter den Eindruck dass
Bullerbü auch ihr Leitbild sein könnte
erklären
aktuellen deutschen Bundestag sind die
Grünen die kleinste Bundestagsfraktion
eigentlich mit dem größten Maul
die Differenzen der Parteien sind
deutlich die Grünen wollen vermögende
stärker belasten die FDP schließt
Steuererhöhungen aus die Grünen wollen
das Klima auch mit Verboten schützen die
FDP will das explizit nicht ein
gemeinsamer Nenner könnte die
Bildungspolitik sein einheitlicher und
digitaler das wollen beide in den Tagen
nach der Wahl wird auch schon über
Personalfragen diskutiert das
Finanzministerium würden beide gerne
besetzen Grüne und FDP schnell gibt es
erste Gespräche mit Beweisfotos
ein Bild voller politischer Signale seht
her wie gut die Stimmung ist wir
bestimmen das wann und wo und wir sagen
auch wie und von allen Vieren und
gleichzeitig veröffentlicht die
Botschaft an alle gemeinsam
selbstbewusst und als Text auf der Suche
nach einer neuen Regierung loben wir
Gemeinsamkeiten und Brücken über
Trennendes aus und finden sogar welche
spannende Zeiten mehr ist vom ersten
vorvor Sondierungsgespräch zwischen FDP
und Grünen auch am Tag danach nicht zu
erfahren sichtbar zufrieden der erste
Aufschlag hat funktioniert
deswegen dieses Gespräch bleibt
vertraulich
und auch das ein Bild von diesem Tag die
Bundestagsfraktion der gestärkten SPD
versammelt sich größer jünger und
ebenfalls selbstbewusster gelassen daher
der rote Blick auf das erste grün-gelbe
Date grün und gelb aber geben das Tempo
vor und weiter gilt zuerst sie dann erst
mit der SPD und der Union es kommt eben
auf das rechte Bild an und auf das
richtige Timing
denn 2017 es soll sich nicht wiederholen
damals fanden die jamaika-verhandlungen
öffentlich quasi auf dem Balkon statt
nichts wurde geheim gehalten es fehlte
an Vertrauen an Augenhöhe an gemeinsamen
Linien das Ende es ist bekannt es ist
besser nicht zu regieren als falsch zu
regieren
wirklich um eine modernisierungsagenda
und dafür war damals der Mut bei den
Gesprächspartnern noch nicht da und
diesmal diesmal ist alles anders es sind
andere Zeiten andere Bilder die
Kommunikation untereinander ist viel
besser die nach außen naja wir sind
heute schmale übrig auch dazu können wir
heute nichts weiteres sagen es ist ein
anderer ein besserer Umgang miteinander
betonen alle die schon vor vier Jahren
dabei waren der Auftakt der ersten
sondierungswoche ist das komplette
Gegenteil zu der Art und Weise wie die
Jamaika Sondierungen vor vier Jahren
geführt worden sind zum Glück es geprägt
von Respekt Wertschätzung von
Vertraulichkeit wir kommen aus sehr
unterschiedlichen Richtungen aber wir
wollen beide den Aufbruch auch die
Herangehensweise anders als 2017 damals
wurde ausgiebig verhandelt schon in der
Sondierung des heißgefaltet als seines
Koalitionsverhandlungen diesmal wird
nach der großen Linie gesucht Robert
habe in Schleswig-Holstein bei dem
jamaika-verhandlungen bewiesen dass es
auch anders geht sein Ansatz erst einmal
Gemeinsamkeiten ausloten eine Basis
zwischen denen finden die am weitesten
voneinander entfernt sind aber hey es
kann was Neues entstehen Deutschland
Hallo schlaft ihr noch es kann was Neues
entstehen ist ja eigentlich eine coole
Situation also vielleicht mit dem Spirit
da rein zu gehen
kann ja auch eine Energie freisetzen und
auf die setzen wir der Anfang ist
gemacht und die verhandlungsorte haben
anders als 2017 keinen Balkon
vorsichtshalber
Anfang Oktober sind es noch vier
Parteien die regieren wollen die etwas
suchen Schnittmengen gemeinsam ist die
erstmal nur reden prüfen messen fühlen
und Pokern die um die Macht der Bilder
Wissen jedes einzelne wohl kalkuliert
viele Bilder viele treffen
Union und SPD trafen sich nicht das
haben sie ausgeschlossen beide
Grüne und FDP trafen sich gleich zweimal
SPD mit FDP und Grünen die Union mit der
FDP dann noch grüne und Union
sondierungsmarathon und langsam wird es
ernst der Zauber des Anfangs verflogen
die flirt-atmosphäre zwischen FDP und
SPD etwas abgekühlt und die SPD will 12
€ Mindestlohn wir sagen dass wir wohnen
bezahlbar machen wir wollen stabile
Renten aber der Sinn von Verhandlung ist
jetzt zu gucken wo sind Schnittmengen es
geht jetzt gar nicht darum rote Linien
zu formulieren doch genau das tat die
FDP formulierte gleich zwei rote Linien
Schuldenbremse bleibt und keine
Steuererhöhung
und die FDP rückt von dieser Position
auch nicht ab das ist eine klare Aussage
gewesen aber und ein klares Signal
Achtung uns das Ernst das ist es auch
der SPD die sagt's noch nicht hat es
aber schon aufgeschrieben im
Wahlprogramm wir werden eine
einkommenssteuerreform vornehmen die
kleine und mittlere Einkommen besser
stellt und dafür im Gegenzug die oberen
5% stärker heranzieht ein Fall für den
Paartherapeuten den FDP und Union wohl
kaum bräuchten ihr Gespräch eine Stunde
länger als geplant und unüberhörbar
positiv wir haben einen gemeinsames
Verständnis in diesem Gespräch
geschaffen dass etwas Neues entstehen
muss weil die Herausforderung so groß
sind dass auch nur mit neuen Ansätzen
diese großen Aufgaben für die Zukunft
Deutschlands bewältigt werden können für
ein solches Jamaika-Bündnis wiederum
bräuchte es mehr Nähe zu den Grünen die
ihrerseits mit der SPD sondierten wo es
wohl auch ganz harmonisch lief
wir haben auch bei der SPD eine
Bereitschaft gefunden und festgestellt
tatsächlich noch einmal neu zu starten
eine Dynamik zu entfachen die dann ja
auch die liegen gebliebenen Probleme
vielleicht lösen kann also Ampel oder
doch Jamaika auch wenn sich die Grünen
nicht festlegen die Chancen für eine
gemeinsame Zukunft mit der CDU stehen
schlecht wir warten auf Ergebnisse bzw
wir warten auf Stellungnahmen dieser
ersten Sondierungsgespräche zwischen der
Union und den Grünen ob der weitere Weg
so geht das Entscheiden natürlich FDP
und Grüne die werden sich ja jetzt
wieder zusammenfinden die Union
jedenfalls ist bereit
klar ist in gerade
gesellschaftspolitischen Bereichen
stehen unsere Parteien eher weiter
auseinander wenn alle bereit wären
aufeinander zuzugehen gäbe es glaube ich
große Chancen so ein Gespräch
vorzusetzen aber vielen Dank für den
Austausch und wir sind gespannt wie es
weitergeht
Berlin im abtast-modus Jamaika oder die
Ampel wohin schlägt das Pendel aus
manchmal geht alles ganz schnell selbst
in Berlin 10 Uhr Reichstag die Grünen
haben eingeladen zum Statement der
Parteichefs sie hätten intern beraten
sagt Annalena baerbock
gekommen dass es sinnvoll ist jetzt
vertieft mit FDP und SPD weiter zu
sprechen auch SPD und FDP wollen
sondieren ist Jamaika damit vom Tisch in
der Union jedenfalls wächst die
Enttäuschung CDU-Chef Laschet hingegen
wartet ab die Hoffnung auf ein Bündnis
mit FDP und Grünen gibt er noch nicht
auf wir haben signalisiert wir stehen
auch zu weiteren Gesprächen bereit aber
die Entscheidung mit wem man in welcher
Reihenfolge spricht liegt bei FDP und
Grünen und deshalb unser Respekt für die
Entscheidung wir stehen bereit als
Gesprächspartner CDU
so viel Geduld bringt die bayerische
Schwester nicht mehr auf grün und FDP
hätten sich entschieden sagt CSU-Chef
Söder in München die Union ist auch
nicht jetzt nach einer so klaren
Vorprägung des Ersatzrad und nur dazu da
quasi immer ein gewisses Druckmittel zu
erzeugen in den Verhandlungen Kampf ums
Kanzleramt das pendelt schlägt aus in
Richtung Ampelkoalition ist Folgen
Sondierungsgespräche zu dritt die Laune
ist gut dabei gibt es jede Menge rote
Linien etwa beim Klimaschutz die Grünen
wollen schon 2030 raus aus der Kohle ein
Tempolimit und dann noch emissionsfreie
Autos beim Kohleausstieg sind SPD und
FDP sich einig spätestens 2038 Tempo 130
aber plant die SPD auch dazu 15
Millionen Elektroautos
Tempolimit oder ein Aus für den
Verbrenner das wollen die Liberalen
nicht
vielen Dank Christian Lindner kann sie
gut gebrauchen die kleine Stärkung auch
die FDP hat ihre roten Linien etwa bei
Steuern keine Steuererhöhung keine
Aufweichung der Schuldenbremse zur
Schuldenbremse steht auch die SPD sie
aber will höhere Steuern für
Gutverdiener und auch Vermögen ebenso
die Grünen für Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz planen Sie auch neue
Schulden
Olaf Scholz will Kanzler werden und
braucht beide Partner zum Regieren
Scholz muss deshalb ausbalancieren für
seine SPD markierte Mindestlohn die rote
Linie die Sozialdemokraten wollen ihn
auf 12 € anheben genau wie die Grünen
eine Lösung mit der FDP scheint machbar
sie würde das Thema gerne der
mindestlohnkommission von Arbeitgebern
und Gewerkschaften überlassen
als sie immer noch mehr Mikrofone
aufstellen wird eines klar wenn so viele
plötzlich gesprächig werden ist das kein
schlechtes Zeichen für die
ampelsondierung hektisch werden Papiere
verteilt und nun wollen alle was sagen
alle fünf Parteivorsitzenden plus
Kanzlerkandidat um genau zu sein
wir haben uns auf einen
Papier einen Text zur Sondierung
verständigt der jetzt die Grundlage für
die Entscheidung in den Parteien bilden
kann die ganze Nacht bis in den frühen
Morgen haben sie im Geheimen noch über
eben jenes Papier verhandelt manche
sieht man das auch an Christian Lindner
hat sich für die Gelegenheit ein paar
besondere Worte notiert
wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
Gesprächen
es lange Zeit
keine vergleichbare Chance gegeben hat
Gesellschaft
Wirtschaft und Staat zu modernisieren
dafür kann jeder der drei ein paar
Punkte machen die SPD bekommt 12 €
Mindestlohn und es gibt keine
Rentenkürzung die FDP erreichte dies es
gibt kein Tempolimit keine
Steuererhöhung auch die Schuldenbremse
bleibt
damit wir nicht nur auf dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner weiter Politik in
diesem Land machen sondern in einer
fortschrittskoalition auch für eine
wirkliche Erneuerung sorgen war es
wichtig dass bei drei unterschiedlichen
Parteien ein Verständnis da ist dass
jeder auch mal was gibt und umgekehrt
bekommt die Grünen viele ihrer
klimaforderungen die Ampel verspricht
Deutschland auf den 1,5°-weg zu bringen
den Kohleausstieg vorzuziehen wenn
möglich auf 2030 und Solarenergie für
alle geeigneten Dachflächen
zuerst macht die SPD den Weg frei für
offizielle Koalitionsverhandlungen grüne
und fdp-folgen es geht voran